édition spéciale de son économie ce soir
consacrée ou vraie raison de la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre deux entrepreneurs avec
nous maintenant pour poursuivre cette
émission louis têtu qui les chefs de
direction d'entreprises d'intelligence
artificielle coveo et francine brûlé qui
fondatrice propriétaire des restaurants
des enfants terribles bonsoir bonsoir
deux secteurs vraiment très différents
mais vous avez tous les deux des enjeux
de main d'oeuvre monsieur têtu d'abord
vous êtes trop au coeur du secteur des
technologies de l'information dans votre
secteur quelle est la vraie raison de la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
mais la vraie raison est vide mais les
ailes et multidimensionnelle mais je
pense qu'à la base ce qui s'est passé
dans les délits 20 dernières années
c'est qu'on a peut-être manqué à voir
venir la transformation numérique on a
vu le secteur numérique disons comme une
verticale ou si on veut on appelait sur
le secteur de la technologie en import
on a mal compris que la technologie
c'est est l'apanage de toutes les
entreprises de toutes les industries et
même de nos institutions qu'on aurait
des besoins criants évidemment et les
gouvernements n'ont pas saisi
l'opportunité disons de bien investir
letta l'un et puis le produit de notre
éducation dans le secteur numérique dans
nos entreprises alors on se retrouve
évidemment avec des retards lors
important dans la robotisation
l'automatisation et tout est évidemment
là on a une pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui
vient
exacerber le problème ok parfait dans
votre dos dans votre domaine madame
brûler vous avez des problèmes quand
même très sérieux puis on le vu que tout
le monde l'a constaté de personnel qui
vous empêchent de fonctionner
normalement pour vous c'est quoi la
vraie raison de la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans le secteur de restauration
je pense que mélange de raison
la pcu c'est certain que ça a joué pour
un certain
nombre de nos employés mais aussi les
gens se sont reposés des questions après
pendant cette pandémie le se sont
retrouvés sans travail et ont trouvé des
dans d'autres domaines j'ai plusieurs
employés leur qui était directeur
sous-chef salah très intéressant mais se
retrouve sans rien et ils ont regardé
ils ont trouvé du travail dans la
construction dans cette vie complètement
plus ils y ont réalisé que même super
maison soit on travaille pas et fin de
semaine on a alors on a perdu un bon
nombre de très bons employés à cause de
ce pack audois pis si la présence est ce
que tous les jeunes qu'on ne peut plus
avoir parce que il gagnait il
travaillait quelques-uns pendant l'été
gagné 3,5 à savent mais ils se sont tous
retrouvés que cette ambiance par semaine
à ça ça nous a affectés énormément aux
caisses qui a vu comme comme résultat
qu'on n'a pas pu ouvrir nos commerces
épouvantable après tout cette cette
pandémie fallait choisir les jours on
faisait du 50 % 60 pour ça de nos
horaires habituels à ça c'est très
difficile donc vous établissez bien les
raisons vraiment qu'ils touchent votre
secteur en tout cas les premières là qui
viennent à l'idée des tuteurs de
complications bien sûr dans votre corps
monsieur été tué ce qu'on a est ce que
vous pensez qu'on a donnée parce que ça
fait longtemps qu'on investit dans les
technologies et dans la création
d'emplois et dans l'attraction
d'entreprise technologique au québec
est-ce qu'on a trop donné à des géants
étrangers géant du web l'intelligence
artificielle de jeux vidéo au point de
manquer de main d'oeuvre chez nous mais
je pense que poser la question c'est y
répondre en partie parce que on constate
le constat est évident aujourd'hui
oui évidemment monsieur godbout en a
parlé tantôt je pense que le calcul
démographique il était faisable
vous savez que nous on était dans une
entreprise capital et aulas qui était
une entreprise québécoise mais qui était
le leader mondial du recrutement par
internet et en 2008 on avait le data
pour démontrer que dans le domaine
numérique là ce qui est ce qui est tout
tout ce qui touche l'automatisation la
robotisation les logiciels les
analytiques institutes
on était en plein emploi alors
évidemment à partir du moment où on
prenait le produit de notre éducation et
puis au lieu de l'investir chez nous
justement pour robotisés et automatisés
moderniser nos entreprises et enlever
les facs dans les hôpitaux au moment où
on faisait ça bien évidemment on
exportait
la valeur ajoutée de notre éducation et
en même temps et on importait de la
rareté et on a acquis des raretés
d'inflation alors bon il faut trouver
des solutions maintenant est ce que est
ce que dans vos solutions monsieur têtu
vous êtes obligés maintenant parce que
vous êtes un homme d'affaires prospère
votre entreprise va bien vous faites des
acquisitions encore récemment acheté à
l'international pour avoir des employés
voilà en partie ces tunnels c'est une
raison on vient d'acheter la semaine
dernière une société de 90 employés à
londres c'est une raison cc c'est parce
que on trouve du talent on diversifie
dame a le talent mais vous savez on doit
compenser avec de l'argent on a importé
évidemment des devises étrangères on a
importé des standards de compensation
étrangers on a importé volet c'est un
problème ceci dit que si on n'est pas
les seuls à l'avoir là dans le domaine
de la transformation numérique comme je
vous dis c'est que on l'a on l'a pas vu
venir la vague de transformation
numérique qu'on l'a mal calculé comme
société est évidemment vous parliez
tantôt avec vos vos invités de
robotisation et tout ça prend des gens
pour robotisée ça prend des gens
spécialisés là pour pourvoir baptisé
pour automatiser et où robotisation je
sais pas si c'est une solution dans le
milieu de la restauration certainement
pas au complet peut être pour certaines
activités mais c'est comment vous faites
madame brûlé pour
garder vos employés à tirer vos employés
vous êtes rendus à faire quoi écoutez on
abandonne
majorer le salaire de la plupart de nos
employés oui on essaie vraiment de leur
donner un environnement le plus agréable
possible
dans le milieu de la restauration en
leur offrant de travailler quatre jours
semaine de vraiment prendre en
considération leurs besoins on les
écoute qu'ils ont besoin de dette comme
on en est un qui est revenu le
dernièrement il ya trois petites filles
alors on travaille avec lui pour qu'il
soit sûr qu'ils partent chercher ses
enfants on travaille mais on est limité
en restauration parce qu'on dirait que
tout à coup des gens veulent plus
travailler soit peu plus travaillé cette
semaine si je mens
mais c'est parce que c'est dur quand
même taille en restauration ceux ci
seraient en réalité c'est très très très
dur honnêtement c'est un métier qui fait
fantastique j'adore ces bois samba
m'anime ça fait j'adore ça mais c'est un
métier qui est exigeant on travaille
avec le public que ça faisait beaucoup
d'audace et c'est beaucoup de stress
alors c'est un métier qui est demandé
aux limouxins venez vous même à payer
plus charge je pense je pense à
l'exemple du plongeur dans un restaurant
qui sera payé plus cher que d'autres
personnes dans le restaurant pour avoir
des plongeurs est longue on y pense on s
photo on essaye d'en trouver un moment
donné puis une chance que c'est le fait
c'est ça on réalise de plus en plus
l'importance de chacun des employés
parce qu'on on prenait pourrait qu'il le
moment de nous on se rend compte que ça
ne pas plonger forêt était de servir et
puis d'assiette je me suis retrouvé en
arrière en plongée un moment donné parce
que chaque saison a ressorti un peu plus
entre yves guillemot nous allons ne lave
vaisselle parce que sinon on arrête de
servir nos clients excuses et a depuis
de vaisselle à la cca ces avances ont
trouvé un boulot longeard oui on veut
bien rénumérés bon louis têtu qu'est ce
que vous faites pour garder vos employés
pour trouver des employés
jusqu'à quelle offre vous êtes rendus
écoutez d'abord il ya eu une inflation
alors forcément il faut compenser avec
des ressources financières
on ne sait pas c'est pas c'est pas le
seul la seule chose je pense que il ya
la main d'oeuvre je pense s'est
modernisée dans notre cas dans le bon
sens a dit que les employés recherchent
plus que simplement un salaire mais un
environnement de travail on dit en
anglais le prix opus veulent comprendre
veulent travailler pour une mission
auquel ils croient de ne pas venir
travailler dans un environnement qui est
collaboratif veulent avoir de la
flexibilité
alors évidemment la pandémie nous a
démontré que le télétravail c'était
possible est ce que c'est possible
d'être 100% télétravail moi je prétends
que il faut bien gérer le mélange parce
que les entreprises on a vu se sont
vraiment c'est un petit bruit le sens si
l'eau on a pu les rencontres impromptues
qu'on avait là la machine à café et tout
alors on cherche à mettre les gens sains
mais accommoder la flexibilité en même
temps et a donné des add à créer des
nouveaux environnements je pense que
c'est ce qui va ressortir c'est très
bien en soit le hockey le milieu de
travail merci d'avoir partagé vos
réalités louis têtu francine brûlé merci
d'avoir été avec nous mercenaire
étudiants pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit